so you are the master you're the master
of Dragon Ball fighters see we have it
on record but he did not play in his
main who's your main ok trunks over
there alright so nice and this is the
competition sir first of all you got
seeing here wrong man
Dragon Ball fighting Z man you gotta go
easy one even though it's not your main
let's see what's the aegyo we've been
waiting on this with switch for a while
[Laughter]
let's go you didn't think this become a
switch it's out our switch now you're
gonna get some good competition going on
let's get it
look a little switch off
[Music]
whoa-oh-oh-oh-oh serious
[Music]
a
that
[Music]
all right but up a fight there man
[Music]
the defense made this play all nice
always getting busy down
okay okay
[Music]
Wow Wow holy okay okay you need to stop
what you doing out here
[Music]
okay there we go that's right baby
that's right there you go there you go
get him now that was that was really bad
yeah yeah you may have broke my record
Wow look you fought valiantly you got to
get back in there you got to get back in
it got dusted off get back in there
that's right
steel sharpens steel oh yeah pretty
match steel sharpens steel just how you
get better man okay yeah play loads here
how about that how about you bring your
power level down again be immortal be
immortal you know
all right Brendan if our down he's not
taking it is 18 taking the seating you
know go do it
[Music]
all right bringing it bringing his power
level down now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right here we go right match number
two
[Music]
seems
Hey
there you go okay there we go oh you
learn now it's on
you're just a mere mortal this time oh
you coming back show no we woke them up
we welcome a hug we woke them up dammit
I can't move Oh Lord Jesus
oh there you go
then m5 more thrills right after
switching out in this town you got to
switch okay
oh that's crazy
[Music]
[Music]
she got that keep out world I like that
Thomas Mann all he learn it
oh he learned it he tired of you inside
now that's it
he has had enough oh oh what the hell is
that what is that you'll never even see
that nothing as a crazy setup
[Music]
the cops right there okay
let's get it let's get it the student
becomes the master let's go let's go
steel steel sharpens steel gotta do it
[Music]
[Music]
attention attention this is it
come on out now you seal the deal close
the gap
you filled all we don't get a seal the
deal they got the tiebreaker I got a
tiebreaker boom well this is it for all
the marbles he fought hard to get finish
position
right take the chair might level up on
you this time I think more we still we
stand we still stay nice now right we
keep it keep the power level even there
you go you better pick your squads do
not fool around
stick with what got you here second
round and second fight all right
spam then do any cheesy tactic necessary
we have no honor we just want the
victory all right this is it
[Music]
all right
[Music]
blending loading screens giving it so
he's ready he's like we're not doing
intros
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
okay okay
oh did act that his cocaine is
[Music]
let's do it
I don't that look good
now look good what is going on 29 inches
[Music]
he's gonna eat them she just ate his
opponent what is happening
[Music]
one and three do it man Oh dad you got
out of there fabulous valiant Gila
valiant you died with honor
yeah a moment that's your moment you can
tell your kids about that time all those
atoms in a second
[Music]
[Music]
okay keep doing it nice block there you
go
oh good Magic Man
listen for your first time that was
pretty that's pretty impressive man
prison president and the champion you
stay away from this machine you stop
harassing these people not good stuff
that your buddy
yeah real good that dragon ball fighters
II man switch